the NRA s big convention was in Dallas
this weekend I didn't go myself because
I'm the second amendment designated
survivor you'd be surprised how often
that rule comes into effect every year
this convention is the chance for gun
makers to attend seminars and forced
laughter at each other's which way to
the gun show jokes but my favorite part
of the NRA convention is seeing the fun
new advances in gun technology and this
year we got to see the product that
answers the question everyone has been
asking why can't my gun look like a
phone one vendor says he's newly
released two balloon iPhone gun will be
the ideal concealed for them put it back
into phones got it my pocket bring it
out
cities yeah it's that easy especially if
you're like this guy and your cell phone
ringtone is already a series of gunshots
you know what it makes total sense
police have been confusing cell phones
for guns in the hands of unarmed black
men for years and now they finally have
a retroactive reason why but the main
event of the NRA convention was our
commander in chief and living embodiment
of a loaded gun Donald Trump who
discussed gun violence with the
sensitivity and dignity it demands boom
come over here come over here whoa boom
come over here bulb come over here it's
also how he appoints his cabinet oh come
on go get over half boom gone huh of
course he's a fair man he didn't leave
out guns biggest competitor knives
nothing easy mr. president save some for
the national knife convention in June
because obviously knife violence is a
thousand times scarier than gun violence
so you can shoot a gun from anywhere but
to use a knife on someone you have to be
close to them and nothing is more
terrifying than intimacy no knives are
the real danger that's why whatever I go
out to dinner I cut my steak with an
ar-15
the Trump knows the NRA convention is
all about reminding us Americans what we
really should be scared of your Second
Amendment rights are under siege
Democrats and liberals and cars wanted
to SARM law-abiding Americans at the
same time they're releasing dangerous
criminal aliens and savage gang members
onto our streets whoa holy I'm
terrified I need a gun that looks like a
chubby iPhone luckily I could exchange
this fear-based adrenaline for lethal
merchandise at any of the 888 booths in
the convention center because the enemy
is out there they're crossing our
borders they're breaking into our homes
and most terrifyingly they're making our
hash browns the NRA tweeted out a
receipt from a company called Ellen's
restaurant in Dallas telling people to
avoid Ellen's because the restaurant put
a message on the receipt saying this
week's proceeds from the restaurant will
be donated to organizations dedicated to
implementing reasonable and effective
gun regulations so the NRA is like no no
boycott Ellis no no yes yes yes boycott
Ellen's
reasonable and effective them's fightin
words some people might ask if the
country's most powerful lobby being
slightly shaded by a restaurant that
serves pancake potpie warrants the
hashtag stand and fight
and the answer is you beg your acid ties
because it just so happens that I did
some digging and found out that Ellen's
URL is grits rule dot-com not in this
country they don't our forefathers
didn't throw grits into Boston Harbor so
that I would have to bow to breakfast
grains it's like a democratically
elected president always says boom boom
knives knives knives
[Music]